chaos dans la plupart des aéroports à
travers le monde montréal ne fait pas
exception
jacob charbonneau a fondé l'entreprise
vols en retard il ya six ans pour
accompagner les voyageurs s'est occupée
oui on est très occupé le téléphone ne
dérougit pas on a des gens qui nous
appellent ampleur parce qu'ils sont dans
une situation pas passer plusieurs qu
est ce qu on entend des choses qu'on
devrait pas entendre
ce soir justement les passagers sont pas
experts resserrement de leurs droits en
effet les passagers ont des droits et
les compagnies aériennes ont des
obligations envers susi en cas de retard
ou d'annulation de vol les passagers
devraient informer toutes les 30 minutes
lors d'un retard de vol sur la situation
et quand est ce que la solution va jouer
ou le prochain vol chaque 30 minutes oui
donc et on voit pas on voit pas ça
présente passe plutôt inverse les
passagers qui courait près de
l'information
pour les balises iodé nombre de
protections a notamment des
indemnisations jusqu'à 2400 $ il ya
aussi un délai très court donc on le 21
jours pour faire la demande
différentes options s'offrent aux
voyageurs pour les protéger la charte
des voyageurs le règlement de protection
des passagers aériens la convention de
montréal la convention de varsovie le
règlement européen 2 6 1 2004 et le
département de transport américain
communément appelé le dot ya également
le fonds d'indemnisation des clients des
agents de voyages si vous avez fait
affaire avec un agent de voyages qui est
titulaire d'un permis du québec le fonds
peut vous indemniser un code défaut d'un
des fournisseurs et ça c'est très
intéressant parce qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir recours au tribunal dans
certains cas il peut y avoir des règles
européennes qui parfois sont peut-être
plus avantageuses ou qu'on a c'est
toujours du cas par cas alors ça vaut la
peine de s'informer les experts
recommandent également de prendre une
assurance voyage personnel ici marie
michèle aux ondes radio canada montréal